today I thought we'd talk about
something called optic flow so this is
something that you might not have heard
about before but it actually turns up in
quite a lot of different things so very
broadly optic flow is about
understanding how things are moving in
an image so the pixel level how motion
is happening so how things are moving
around across the whole image and this
is useful for a number of reasons if
you've got a wobbly shaky camera you can
use it for image stabilization I wasn't
insinuating anything yet so you can use
optic floaters see what kind of global
motion is happening and sort of take
that out drones things like that some of
them have got optical sensors that will
kind of look at sort of how the world is
moving around them so this isn't about
tracking sort of individual objects or
things this is about seeing how the
global motion all the surfaces in the
scene are moving around if you can kind
of break up the scene by motion it's
another way of segmenting an image or
labeling an image if you've seen some
videos about that before so in addition
to things like color or texture you can
use how things are moving around to help
sort of figure out how to divide up a
scene so it's almost like 3d I suppose
if you get a parallax like yeah exactly
rocks here you can see that you're
moving differently to the window exactly
and you can either you can pull out some
other things there as well so things
closer to the camera tend to move faster
so you get kind of an idea of depth and
there's certain techniques such as
something called structure for a motion
which does exactly that it figures out
how things appear in 3d by seeing how
the camera moves around let's have a
think about sort of what's going on in
an image as you move a camera so
obviously an image is composed of loads
of pixels potentially millions of pixels
and when you move your camera around
there's some kind of change happening in
those pixels and what we want to figure
out is how that motion at an individual
pixel level is happening okay so that
means pretty much for every pixel in the
image we want to try and apply some kind
of motion vector to it to understand
where
moving to okay now this is a pretty hard
problem there's many many pixels in the
image and to understand exactly how each
of them are moving we're going to have
to kind of make some assumptions and
some simplifications and that's where
the optic flow techniques cannot come in
so this is a really simple image here
where we've just got sort of one shape
in the middle of it like this
perhaps a ball or something like that
and if we're calculating optic flow
across this image and the ball is moving
what we're going to end up with is
remember this is sort of every single
pixel we're going to get these flow
vectors when we're talking about optic
flow really what we're considering is
sort of the motion at this level within
the object or surface that's moving
what's going on okay so here I've drawn
some pretty fads optic flow vectors
showing that maybe this ball is sort of
moving down and if the background was
moving as well you know perhaps you'd
have lots of vectors over the background
showing that the background was moving a
certain way so different surfaces in the
image can move in different directions
but it's important to remember that
we're just working at the pixel level so
we're trying to pick apart what's
happening on individual pixels within
the image so this is quite complicated
to do because the real world is
complicated so we have to make a lot of
assumptions in order to try and pull out
the motion of essentially these
individual pixels that represent
something called motion flow and that's
something sort of moving through the
real world so if I move something around
that's moving in the real world but how
does it move on the image we've just got
this 2d plane of pixels and so how do we
understand from that how something's
moving sort of in 3d so there's a number
of assumptions that we have to make one
of the assumptions that we have to make
is that the things like the lighting
doesn't change okay so if you if you
think there's this piece of paper if I
move my hand across it and we get a
shadow then optic flow techniques might
pick up on that shadow as being
something actually moving in the image
rather than just the lighting changing
so one thing we have to assume is that
lighting isn't isn't changing too much
and obviously in the real world that's
quite challenging because we get lots of
shadows and and stuff happening that we
it's going to confuse these kind of
approaches so another sort of
simplification that we make is that when
we're looking at this flow we only do it
over very small changes in time so I'm
like tracking where we might be
following something through a whole
video sequence here we're just looking
at two frames so we're take two
neighboring frames out of a video and
see how the pixels have moved between
them as well as having things like
lighting changing which can break optic
flow another problem we can get sort of
the other way round is that maybe
there's not enough features on a surface
to be able to detect the difference
anyway I was going to show you an
example with a ball but the only really
show anymore like find was this tiny one
so if you spin it it's spinning of
course but you can't see it spinning
because you can't see the texture
turning round on the ball especially
because it's reflecting lighting which
isn't moving so one of the problems we
have with optic flow is that we're
making all these assumptions you know
such that we can actually see things
moving and that's not always true one of
the key constraints we make when we're
writing down how we're going to
calculate optic flow is this idea of a
brightness constraint and what that
really means is if we've got our image
here like this we've got the intensity
at a particular point so this point here
our brightness in our image so our
grayscale value so the higher is in the
new year is to white the lower is near
it is to black is that a position X
comma Y so that's our pixel at a
particular time T and what we're
thinking about is essentially where has
the thing at that pixel here moved to in
the next frame so it's going to have
moved only a little bit even much more
than that actually but less to it like
that so we've got our new position here
that we think this information has moved
to whoever's in the real world has moved
here in the image and so this is going
to be essentially the brightness X plus
a little bit Y plus a little bit at t
plus a little
so we've got some changes happening in
space X plus a little bit y plus a
little bit and also a change happening
in time as well so because we've got
these little changes you can use
actually derivatives you can use some
neat tricks where we're just looking at
gradients in the image to figure out
this equation we can rewrite it as
something called the optic flow equation
which just basically uses image
derivatives to look at changes in
grayscale over very tiny patches of
course if you want to calculate
derivatives in in an image you can use
things like kernels like this a barrel
kernel which I think Mike's done a video
on before so the math spoils down to
essentially being able to do pixel wise
calculations to do with grayscale so
looking in neighboring regions to see
changes in space and looking at changes
over time as well so differences between
frames I'm looking at that now from my
videographer head and thinking for K 60
frames per second yeah this is a loss
calculator right so there's a few tricks
so perhaps at least nicely onto how a
few people have solved this because this
is the problem and actually now you've
got a load of different optimization
techniques that will try and give you
these vectors where we've moved to here
this is kind of known as U and V so
these are our motion vectors that we've
got everywhere in the image and you're
right it can take a little while to
calculate that
we've thought about how you can talk
about optic flow with little changes in
space and little changes in time that
means derivatives and say things like
Sibel which we have had a camera with a
fairly high ISO settings you had a lot
of grainy noise that's going to produce
it full of low-level edge over
everything